kristen i noticed you drinking a giant
jug of something what's in it may i ask
green tea if you don't mind we're going
to find out the truth
about the other fun factoids that we
said about you
going into commercial break um
and now we're gonna guess which one is
true all right again i
i don't know anything so um
i believe it's d all of the above it is
d
all of the above i memorized press on
neil's commercial when i was little
i still have it put to memory i eat
cereal like candy because it's
cereal is delicious and i have a uh
in my desk drawer a big bag
with rice in it and it is labeled when
mom drops her
cell phone in water not if
mom drops her cell phone in water it
really does work
um i want to hold up your beautiful
book the world needs more purple people
my friend ben and i we were sitting
around the dinner table
and just seeing a very polarizing
political culture seep into our little
kids daily lives and we wanted to create
some language to help so that
you know the metaphor of it it's not
secret is that red plus blue equals
purple and we just
we didn't want any of our kids looking
around seeing enemies
and uh because this is the united states
you know so
we figured out the five pillars we loved
that no one could argue with like
purple being a purple person means
laughing a lot uh being silly using your
voice
working hard and then also being
uniquely used so it's about like
celebrating the differences and
uniquenesses
within each other but also not seeing
one another as
enemies looking towards our fellow human
beings and my secret plan
is that the adults will read it with the
kids because
we wrote a kid's book so that the kids
could have some help but i think it's
the adults that need the majority of the
help because there's so much fighting
and divisiveness and i just don't want
america to exist like that with all
that is out there for kids to see
we have to help make sense of it for
them and guide them
to being loving unjudgmental open-minded
open-hearted
grateful and kind beings
i don't think guiding them means staying
secretive you know like we tell our kids
all the time like there's a ton of crazy
crap on the internet that's why you're
not allowed to use it
it's also why you're not allowed to
drive my car or drink alcohol or vote
because you can't read about the
propositions yet so like there's just
certain things that
are meant for an older brain and like i
just don't think you know
pretending like the at least this is how
we do it in our family which
it's different for everyone but we are
very honest with our girls because and
they need i think they need to know what
forms hate
and in our family we talk about the fact
that it's fear
people get fearful and then they start
hating so we got to do our best to
overcome those fears
and remember that we are all human and
we need to
um treat each other that way thank you
for all of
the stuff that you put out into the
world and curate
for us um your children's book the world
needs more purple people
and your skin care line happy dance are
both available right now kristen
it's been so fun to hang out with you
and talk with you
i'm honored truly i adore you i adore
you too
and we made a movie by the way together
back in the day
oh my god kristen
ducky it's your old friend kristen can
you believe it
oh doc i'm just i was so excited to have
you guys reunite